successful people and wealthy people
have a subtle distinction they don't
look at price they look at worse
identity is the governor on our lives
it's the invisible force that no one
understands and once they do understand
and get a hold of their life to change
when you get down when you're in a slump
it's your habits rituals routines and
your standards that carry you through
Juanes or get a mentor what's up believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best ed my
led and some of his best motivation to
help you crush 2019 mentor me IDI
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one stop negotiating the price when I
was poor everywhere I went
flip the price tag oh what's it cost
what's it cost what's it cost what's it
cost I was constantly negotiating the
price for everything in my life you do
that when you come from a place of
scarcity of being poor successful people
and wealthy people have a subtle
distinction they don't look at price
they look at worth is this worth it if
you're constantly looking at the price
tag you'll eventually relent you'll
eventually give in stop negotiating the
price it's a freeing experience to
totally commit when you totally commit
to a relationship to a business to your
fitness to your faith it's a freeing
powerful it's almost like removing
kryptonite from your life when you
totally commit can you do that the
people around you it's costing too much
it's costing too much and you go maybe
it's constant too much you guys are
gonna know it's worth it it's not the
price it's the worst it's a subtle
distinction in your life
rule number two shift your identity
identity is the governor on our lives
it's the invisible force that no one
understands and once they do understand
and get a hold that their life can
change and so not only if you don't get
a hold of this will these outward
conditions of your life keep being
exactly the same but it's you could
behave differently could do all the work
now you could be thinking great thoughts
but you are going to get out of your
life you're gonna be the most powerful
force in the world I think is to be
consistent with the concepts ideas and
worth that you hold for yourself you
will get that out of your life what you
will tolerate okay the deeper part of
that is identity and so the identity is
very much like a thermostat sitting on a
wall right this is important once that
temperature is set at a certain degree
everything in the world externally can
hit it and you will find a way to get
that temperature so even in this house
let's say it's set at 80 degrees if we
opened up all the doors and cold air
just the worst things in life the
blizzard of life came in the thermostat
will kick the heater on and it will
regulate this room back to 80 degrees
the reverse is also true it's a super
hot day great things are happening in
your life it's getting hotter and hotter
and hotter if you're at 80 degrees that
internal thermostat will find a way over
a window of
time to cool your life right back down
to 80 degrees again so the key the
secret key is to be able to shift that
identity 90 120 so some of the ways
strategies to do that are very simple
one is if I let's just say financially
you're a 200-degree or and I'm an
80-degree if I'm in your proximity over
and over and over and over again you
will heat my identity up somewhere in
between mine and yours to 150 degrees
same and fitness same and everything so
the more you can layer in multiple
people the stronger and stronger that
forces so that changes our thermostat
through association it's a huge huge
huge huge thing people say you are who
the five people you hang around this is
why they had just your thermostat that's
number one second way you can change
your identity is through doing short
bursts of something in a window of time
you've not done them before and they
change the thermostat temperature
permanently almost like a water line in
the pool so if it's a certain in the gym
certain amount in the gym or a certain
amount of phone calls in your business
or certain amount of appointments you
make a certain amount of money
oftentimes you're never the same again
you've seen this when your own net worth
I've seen it in mind there became a
point where I made a leap and a short
window I was never really the same again
I could go back a little bit but not
back where I was before
so it's activity or successes
achievements in short bursts of time
rule number three don't sell your will
to win most people's will to win is for
sale it's for sale most people's will
will is for sale win is for sale they
can be Bob I can't be Bob so if we give
you just most people if we give you just
enough money if there's a certain dollar
amount it's not working I always stop
working hard we give you a car or a
plane or a house or that's the book bro
is that the book yeah that might be the
book that is the book so what your will
to win is for sale that's right and I
decided once I realize that because I
watched it happen with people in their
body and their finances and their family
and their faith whatever it is I'm not
for sale so there isn't a place you're
gonna buy me you can't get me there's
not a stop a place a destination where
you're gonna get me to relent to quit I
want to improve that doesn't mean I
don't struggle with my motivation from
time to time
doesn't mean I don't get confused or
down of course idea I'm not for sale
yeah you can't buy me and you know this
too we see a friends of ours even guys
in their 60s and they sold their company
for blah blah blah now they golf nine
days a week or whatever you know that's
fun but yeah for sale
they burbot you or buy you were for sale
I'm not for saying
rule number four always give your all I
remember going all the work I put into
this all the hopes my family and I had
all the travel ball all everything we
did all the games all the great plays
all the errors I made the fly ball I
dropped it Fullerton you know all that
stuff I was gonna get drafted then I did
all that stuff right the guys I played
with over like a flicker man like a
flicker that crap was over and we're on
that bus ride back and I remember
thinking man I should have tried harder
I should have played harder I should
have given this more you know that stuff
guys do man you're running sprints
there's two dudes who run every sprint
full-speed and then there's a dudes who
run 80% six of them you know exactly
what I'm talking about right he's kind
of cool you know doesn't matter not the
fastest guy so no one will know when I
don't win the Sprint's you know those
guys you know exactly what I'm talking
about right this guy kind of doesn't
really catch the ball on his throwing
side in the outfield he's where he
catches it over it does everything wrong
throws it back that's the thing that
costs a guy getting thrown out at third
and you lose by a run because you just
practiced like that guy in the bullpen
it's kind of like not really focused you
just gotta get in loose right instead of
just laser focused on everything he's
doing all the time right you don't want
to leave here you don't want it to end
whether it ends in the big leagues
it ends in the minor leagues it ends
here or you never even get on the field
this year okay
having wondered whether you gave it all
you got cause it's gonna transfer into
the man you become when you leave here
and most important is gonna be your
identity when you get tired when you get
fatigued when you get down when you're
in a slump
it's your habits rituals routines and
your standards that carry you through
and if you don't have good habits you
don't have good rituals you don't have
good routines always in your life you
will fall down and bad times and slumps
and fatigue and and stress and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is grow you I don't
believe in faking it till you make it
you know an entrepreneur is amiss right
it's the greatest self-discovery
process in the history of mankind in it
you learn more about yourself what you
don't know your resiliency how tough you
are what your weaknesses are by being an
arch where it's probably the greatest
self-discovery program in the history of
the world it's also this it's the
greatest self-improvement program with
the highest compensation package
possibly attached to it to that's what
our two entrepreneurs it was a
self-improvement program with massive
compensation package attached to it and
that's why too many of you are to focus
on growing your company and not focus
enough on growing you because your
company will never ever exceed your
identity or your vision for it you got
to grow you cuz what will happen when it
starts to grow you'll start making
unconscious mistakes to shrink it making
bad calls getting weak getting lazy
making mistakes you're all nodding
because you've all done it because at
some point your business got ahead of
you it will never exceed your identity
and your vision because if the company
catches your vision the company catches
your identity you're dying
now I've got a bonus clip from Ed on how
to max out your life that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions on the move from just watching
another video to taking action in your
life or your business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one where do you need to grow
most number two how do you need to shift
your identity to get there and number
three how will you give it your all
see at the end of my life the Lord is
gonna go hey by the way this guy over
here this is the man you could have been
this is the person you were born to be
this would have been your dreams this is
where you would have gone what you would
have seen who you would have helped what
you would have changed this would have
been your book meet him my dream in my
life is that when I meet that person
we're not total strangers you don't want
to get to the end of your life and that
character is a total stranger to you you
know damn well there's gonna be a
funeral for you someday at that funeral
there's gonna be a sense in the spirit
of what you could have become the woman
the man you could have become and every
day those decisions you're making to max
out your life are chasing that person
see you know what I want at the end of
my life when I meet him I want to be
identical twins Chad and Ed are gonna
meet each other someday and I'm gonna
say hey man good to see you been chasing
you man he's ago I've been watching you
you're exactly like me man were
identical twins you maxed out your damn
life congratulations
if you want more admire let check out
the Instagram live interview I did with
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there yeah it's
a beautiful day a little cold so I'm a
little bit buttoned up but it's all good
I'm in Toronto Canada man so cold
there's a whole level